now ross there's a huge tv event this
weekend
and some are even calling it a second
super bowl and we talked about it when
it was first announced
this sunday oprah sits down for a two
hour wow
two hour power interview with prince
harry
and meghan markle and it's their first
high-profile interview
since moving to the us and stepping back
from their royal post and cbs posted a
sneak peek
let's take a look okay you know for me
i'm just really relieved and happy to be
sitting here
talking to you with my wife by my side
because i can't begin to imagine what it
must have been like for her
going through this process by herself
all those years ago
because it has been unbelievably tough
for the two of us but at least we had
each other
okay i am so over the moon i cannot wait
for this are you gonna be camped out in
front of your tv for this
i really will be appointment television
for this
i'm going to set out a whole uh harry
megan crudite i'm going to make
buckingham roll-ups i don't know i'm
just going to go all out i
like oprah is the perfect person for
them to sit down with perfect
and what do you want like where do you
want oprah to go with this interview
i think i would very much appreciate it
to be half a celebration
of the freedom that they fought for
uh so buckingham rolls and all the cute
accoutrements and
to make it feel celebratory because i
think there's been so
much pain and controversy that i would
like to see
a little bit of levity and humanity but
i also
wonder if it will ever be pressed upon
about just the dangers of our society
and what they can lead to
and for that to sink in at some point so
maybe this will be another stepping
stone to that and we rarely get
insight right into that family so i want
to know how
harry and william are i want to know how
megan and kate
are i want to know what the queen puts
out for a breakfast buffet i want to
know
everything we'll be sure to watch on cbs
this sunday at 8 p.m eastern yeah and if
royals aren't your thing
i don't know who you are but maybe
you'll tune in to the critics choice
awards instead they're happening on
sunday night on the cw
and variety reports that yet again mank
make that film on netflix the black and
white one
is out front with 12 nominations minari
is in second with 10
and netflix they have made history with
four
best picture nominations uh the five
bloods by spike lee
ma rainey's black bottom uh by george c
wolfe
mink uh that david fitcher directed and
the trial of chicago seven
some good movies all available for you
to watch right now
on netflix before the the big awards and
for those uh in it just for the fashion
the critics choice always brings some
good looks because the pressure's not
really on like it is for the oscar so
people have a little fun
last year remember zendaya she was
nominated for euphoria look at oh
i will never forget this look i loved it
so
much i've never seen anything like it
beyond florence pugh was nominated for
little women last year
she came wearing this which was gorgeous
he is a knockout
billy porter for pose who always brings
it on the red carpet
yes i mean he's like a combo of so many
things right there it's really
interesting
because it's fun you know the pressure
like i said the pressure's off cersei
ronan
lee could i ever find a dress that looks
like that
i just have to say what you're wearing
today is a little that oh my goodness
you know what we might have to do a side
by side
well at least you know i'm being honest
when i say i like it because i'm wearing
like the
other more casual wearable version here
we go ready
yes yeah clearly i'm into this and look
now drew you're inspiring me look at
this
look oh my gosh
[Applause]
you to me oh like i think you might need
to sport that for the rest of the
segment
okay it's on it's on with tape so we'll
see if it stays
a couple more looks from last year i
sent you a revo for harriet look at this
look which i just oh
my gosh i'm so in love with her and her
stylist they always bring it
they're the ones always to watch and
kristen bell uh from last year as well
let's
look at that that color is so good it's
like a highlighter citron situation
she inspires me in this look to bring it
she looks great
yeah uh all right drew you know we're
talking about spring cleaning since it's
spring we got our flowers on i know you
already started taking on
your coat closet um yes you posted
something on instagram that gives you
major anxiety yes uh yeah this this
freaked me out when i was looking at it
yep
and i have to fit all that in this like
narrow
you know our coat closet is you know
only about
i don't know two feet wide and uh so
i basically took everything out to put
it back in in a different
less chaotic way you have a lot of stuff
all right and now is the time people are
spring cleaning getting it all together
and uh here's some tips for you southern
living reports that
bissell has released a spring cleaning
guide
drew to organize your cleaning spree so
check this out
it breaks tasks into manageable chunks
you can clean a chunk
cross out a chunk clean a chunk cross
out a chunk
you can visually see your slow and
steady progress up spring
cleaning mountain because it is like a
mountain you are climbing when you look
at that pile and go what do you do
so here's a way they say that can help
you sort of
clean it up this turns me on i don't
know how else to say
i am hot to try i'm gonna get on this
calendar
because it talks about cleaning like
drapes and
dog toys and the inside of your washer
all these things that we just don't even
think about
so i think this is sexy and unique
and approachable i'm gonna get you
outside of the box
um from your own routine i am in
i love that you think this is sexy you
are so weird i am
yeah can i ask you are you neat and tidy
totally neat and tidy
i can't handle a mess that's why your ig
was driving me crazy
yeah and really what this list says at
the end of the day if you just break it
down
it start with one thing one at a time
when you're looking at that pile
pick one thing and then on to the next
and on to the next so you don't want a
mountain ross you want a tiny little
molehill hill
uh uh-huh i'm fine with a molehill thank
you
i am the everest of mess all right